and we are live
so
yes we are live sorry I was just
verifying
um hello everyone uh so welcome to the
first live about of deep reinforcement
funding course
um so we're going to start in two
minutes just to wait but you know
everyone who wants to join can join
um I'm super happy to do this live uh
this is the first one since uh since a
long time so yeah
and uh so I'm happy also to see that
there is a lot of people
um so just a quick thing today we're
going to I'm going to present what the
course will be about
and then we will have a q a but in a
funny way because we're going in the
same moment I'm going to play with Huggy
with some of the Huggy you train so for
people who don't know Huggy is
um the reinforcement running dog that
you're going to train to fetch a stick
and some of you already trained it so
we're going to try some
foreign
from
so that I can see a little bit feel long
nice
um Switzerland
so I'm from France if I
Macedonia France of course yeah nice
Montreal
item nice Egypt Bangalore Michigan
Texas Spain oh yeah Arizona
okay
Switzerland to Poland
living in South Korea nice USA Belarus
nice
um so yeah what I was saying is that
um we are going to have two parts one
for 20 minutes where I'm going to
present uh uh explain the colors what it
will look like what the scope uh what
will be the challenges Etc and the
second pathway we're going to do a small
q a
um USA and vanish
okay so let's go and let's remove
her
okay
um
Sri Lanka nice
okay so I'm going to start uh by uh just
uh as I explained you know the live will
be in two parts so the first will be
um a presentation of the course uh so I
will explain the scope the unit and the
challenges you're going to work with uh
it will be approximately 20 minutes I
think it will be a little bit less but I
I I I put this part and the second part
will be a q a where you're going uh I'm
going to play with some of the Huggy
that were trained by by the students and
I'm going to answer some question
um if we don't have time to to answer
all the questions don't hesitate uh to
join our Discord Discord server
where we have a big Community where you
can
um
you can uh participate you can exchange
with your uh with your classmates so
it's a it's a very nice uh very nice
video uh
just sorry I'm just looking
um
okay so as I was saying so we have two
parts so the first part will be
representation of the course and the
salon will be a q a
uh
I'm going to play with Hagi so Hagi is
the second uh unit so the unit bonus uh
where you need to train these cute dogs
to fetch a stick and what's nice is that
you can directly play in your browser so
you don't need to install anything
um and you can load your model directly
in the browser
sorry
[Music]
it's here it's at the yeah you have the
Discord link uh at the bottom of the
screen
um
so yeah as I mentioned we have a Discord
server so the Discord is a central place
where you can uh action with your
classmate uh you can ask questions you
can study together and it's also the
place where we give the last update
information
so yeah to join is very simple it's
hf.com
join slash Discord
[Music]
um
and then uh this is one thing I wanted
to mention before explaining the course
it's a in the Discord we build study
group base where you live so this way
it's it's easier for you because you can
exchange with people who are in close
time zones but obviously you can
participate in every group uh if you
want
um and the second part uh so yes the
video will be recorded uh second part is
um the mail so if you signed up to the
course we got your mail uh if it's not
the case the link is here but the link
is also on the um the Deep reinforcement
learning course on unit zero uh it's
important that you sign up because we
are going to give you information also
by mail so it's to keep you updated and
if so we send you a mail two days ago
and if you didn't receive it first
please check your spine folder because
it might be in the spam folder
and if it's not the case you can send me
a DM on Discord so can I so that I can
verify if you are on your list
uh so yeah again the course is uh in
this uh in this address
and so now I can speak a little bit
about what we are doing what we're going
to do during this course
um so you're going to study deep
reinforcement learning and theory and
practice so Theory because you're going
to learn the theory behind the algorithm
we're going to study so however works
mathematically speaking because it's
very important uh to understand you know
how it works behind the hood but also a
lot of practice because in every unit
you have ends on where you train agents
uh you're going to learn to use famous
deep reinforcement learning library
which is something very important when
you do reinforcement learning so you're
going to learn about uh stable Baseline
free you're going to learn about error
Baseline Zoo sample Factory clean RL but
you're also going to learn to make your
own agent by hand so coding with pytorch
for instance so we're going to do that
with Q learning we're going to do that
with policy gradients and ppos so which
are three different architecture
um and then after that you're going to
train agents in unique environment
so unique environments means we we
created some funny environment such for
instance but there is overs uh
environments you're going to train your
age or not for instance mineral which is
a Minecraft uh environment uh this Doom
which is a doom version uh open source
Doom version so Zoom it's a first person
shooters very famous One
um but also ml agent environments so
which are environments created with
unity which is a game engine you're
going to learn about that in unit 5.
so we we wanted to make something nice
you know uh you're also using classical
environment what we call classical
environment in reinforcement running so
for instance
um uh gym environments artery
environments
um so yeah so this is some of the
environments are going to train your
agent on so at the top right it's a
snowball fight it's a game we created uh
at the bottom right you have Doom uh you
see Minecraft You See Space Invaders uh
you see Huggy and there is much more
environments I didn't put everyone every
every environment
and yeah something very interesting is
that you can share your train agent with
one line of code to the hub such as
dragging face Hub and also the not cover
full agent from the community
so what's nice is that on the hugging
phase Hub you can push your model your
Trend models uh think of having Face Hub
as the GitHub for your train models and
um this way you can visualize your agent
playing with a video as we see on this
screenshot and you have information
about your engine on the left and what's
nice is that you can push a model but
you can also load very powerful model
for instance this one was created by
stable Baseline free community so people
who create this double bass line free so
they are very very good models but you
can load in one line of code and it's
something you learn in the unit one
which we're going to learn for every
unit because what's nice is that every
reinforcement like learning library that
you're going to to study uh have
integration with a game face Hub it
means that for every every office
Library you will be able to push uh the
model on the Hub and and you will be
able to share it very easily and for
free
um and the final one which is I think
one of the most interesting is that you
will participate in challenges where you
will evaluate your agents against uh
over over agents and again software team
so it's something you you will know more
a little bit in January but I want to
explain a little bit uh there is two
types of challenges the first that if
you start the the course you already saw
it's uh we'll get the best course so
it's it's a challenge for fun it's one
because it's uh you have a leaderboard
where when you push your model to the
hub you we created the leaderboard where
you can see what is your rank with your
classmates and what's nice is that if
you click on another classmates you can
see uh you know the score
and what's nice about is uh you can you
know seize the API parameters that were
used so that you know you can improve
your own agent
um I'm just looking uh this agents Unity
agents so some of the agents are initi
agent Phantom snowball fight but I'm
going to talk just after
um but not all uh so and the second part
that's very interesting and I'm very
excited to to speak about this one but
you will have more information in
January it's AI versus AI so the idea is
that we created a multi-agent
environment for instance Noble height
where are we going to train your own
agent and then we compete with other
classmates so you will load your agents
you will load the classmate agents and
you will see who we will win and so you
we're going to have a leaderboard
um I will not dive too much on that for
now because uh we're working on that and
we want to uh to show you that later but
I just wanted to give you a little sneak
peek on that
um so it's a good way to learn uh these
challenges are a good good way to learn
um the leaderboard for for
um for the models are more something for
fun so don't don't be disappointed if
you have a low score or low rank
um I think the mindset to have here is
to think how you can improve and ask
your classmates what they've done so
that you can learn from them
uh yeah so this is one of the examples
of this is Noble fights which is one of
the uh so this version is a beta version
but it's one of the environments we
created and you're going to uh to
challenge your classmate with your AI
so I'm just going to to speak a little
bit about what will be the two first uh
environment that you're going to work on
so if you go to the course uh you have
uh the first one is
um Luna longer so it's the first uh
agent you're going to train so as you
can see in another you you're trying to
rely on other agent that needs to learn
to learn on the moon and to do that it
needs to learn to activate different
engine to not crash so this is what you
do on the first unit
that I mentioned before you're going to
train Hagi the Dogo so uh also but to
fantastic and play with him in on your
browser uh some of you already done it
so yeah it's uh it's um it's very nice
we have already very nice huggage
um is this YouTube only on our Zoom
class so we um yeah it's something I
forgot to mention so if you go let me
share my screen
yeah so if you go
and
um
yeah Cycles if you go uh on the course
so hugging HF dot core slash deep error
course
um it's where the course is you have a
formula as you need one bonus unit
um and you need zero
and
um you have so subsection you know with
uh we we made very nice uh you know
illustration Etc and you have the enzyme
so enzyme is here and what's nice is
that for the first Amazon we have a
video if you prefer because some people
want to dive directly on Google collab
but you can direct you can also follow
with the video
uh we we will have a video for every uh
hands-ons
uh and we will have as I mentioned we
are we'll have these slides which will
be more q a and action with the
community uh we aim to do that one every
week
um so if I go back here
so again the course is on hf.com red
course
um and yeah so what I wanted to mention
now is that there is two path for this
course uh obviously this course is
totally free I repeat it it's totally
free
um you can either just participate as a
simple audit so you can do the challenge
assignments but you will not have any
deadlines
um or you can be you can't want to get a
certificate of completion so in that
case you need to complete 80 of this
assignment so it means you need to do 80
of the enzyme uh before the end of March
uh whatever the path you choose to take
uh we recommend you to follow uh the
recommended page that I'm going to show
you after to enjoy you know the
challenge at the same time but everyone
and to to get the most of the course
with your classmates
um so this is a recommended pace of the
course uh so it's it's obviously it's
just an advice you can you can you can
handle whenever as you want but
um we so this is the first unit so the
unit one introduction to deep
reinforcement learning where you learn
you know the basics a different
enforcement learning Japanese units it's
one you train algae introduction to Q
learning will be published next week
you're going to learn your first
reinforcement learning algorithm culture
learning which is a value-based
reinforcement learning algorithm then
you're going to learn about GQ learning
which is uh q-learning on steroids uh
it's a version that use a deep neural
network to estimate the Q value and it's
it's very famous it's a very famous
algorithm because it was the first one
that shows the power of using deeper
enforcement reinforcement learning and
deep learning together
uh when we're going to have a new pair
parameter search with optuna units so
what's very hard when you do different
enforcement learning is to find a good
set of HIPAA parameters fortunately for
us there is some libraries that can do
the Epi parameter search and so you're
going to learn about it it's a very
powerful Library
and then we're going to have a very
interesting unit about ml agents so ml
agents is uh is a library based on Unity
so for people who don't know Unity is a
game engine where you can create very
powerful game there is a lot of famous
game made with unity but what's nice is
that now you can create different
enforcement learning environment with
unity
so in introduction to a management agent
we are going to learn how to train
agents with uh with unity and there we
also provide some additional readings on
how you can create your own environments
uh but keep in mind that if you want to
create your own environment you will
need to learn to use Unity but uh we
will give you you know some additional
resources such as because Unity provide
a lot of free courses to to learn to
create games with uh with verandign
and then we will have the interesting
part the most interesting part I will
say every part is interesting but this
one I think is the most exciting one
it's the introduction to multi-agent it
means how you can have multiple agents
that either compete against each other
or collaborate
and uh you're going to train your agent
in a lot of multi-agent environment that
we created and it's where the challenge
AI versus AI uh will start
um then we are going to learn about
policy gradients which is a policy based
method that is very important to
understand in order to understand the
state of the art reinforcement planning
algorithm
after that we're going to learn about
actor critic methods with doom don't
worry if you don't understand the term
funnel it's um you it's uh you're going
to to understand it more and more as you
go further in the course but actor
critic is a hybrid method between a
value-based reinforcement running
algorithm and a policy based
reinforcement running algorithm and
you're going to train it on a doom game
uh and finally on Unit 8 we're going to
learn about one of the state-of-the-art
algorithm uh generalist algorithm called
PTO proximal policy optimization and
we're going to have a bonus unit where
we're going to talk about uh offline
reinforcement learning decision
Transformer so it's the use of
Transformer model uh to create
reinforcement deep reinforcement
learning agents we're also going to talk
uh all about you know human feedback uh
training in the language model with
human feedback and about that we're
going to have next week normally on
Tuesday but we will give you more
information uh uh soon about that but we
are going to have a live where we're
going to talk about reinforcement
learning from Human feedback which is
the technology that was used to train
chat gbt so I I think a lot of people a
lot of people already heard about GPT so
yeah we're going to talk about that next
week
um we're going to give you the the
Lincoln ETC on the Discord and we're
going to send you uh on the mail
but I just wanted to give you a little
sneak peek about that
to submit assignments sorry I just saw
the question uh yeah you just need to
publish the model talking phase so when
you finish the collab you push the model
to the hub
yeah we're going yeah next week uh we're
going to have a uh
um sorry a live about uh this technology
so yeah
um I wanted to have some uh just to
mention some best practices so the first
is uh you should join uh the study
groups in this code
um to be honest I when I started to
study the reinforcement running in 2018
I don't need like a loan and it was
really not a good idea reinforcement is
super interesting but interesting but
um it's sometimes a little bit complex
so working with other people it's very
nice and so as I mentioned we created
study groups based on uh where you live
uh it's it's more because this way you
can uh you know be in the same close
time zone with other people but
obviously you can
um you can you know work in any group
you want
um
yeah so is it considered submitted even
if your agent is not on the top of the
leaderboard so what we wanted that we
want to your agent to have a certain
score so for instance for linear loader
is 200. uh no you don't need to be on
the top of a board because there is so
much models it's uh it will not make
sense because you know only a few people
will get the certificate ID just that
you succeed to get to certain good score
and we are going to
um to put the score of every unit you
need to attend in order uh to pass as
the certification process
the second thing is do the quiz and
assignment uh because you know we have
something called I talk a lot about that
that we have something called you know
illusion of competence is when you think
you you learn something but
um if you test yourself you will
discover around no so what we do is that
during the course we have some quizzes
that are uh optional quizzes you know
that don't count for for the
certification but they are very good to
to verify that you know you you Masters
the new Masters know the the
uh the notion
and so yeah I would strongly advise you
to do the assignment and to do the
assignment without the solution first
and you know it's it's very no more in
the beginning to to have some bugs and
to have some things like that and I
still have a lot of that so it's very
normal in in the world left lifetime so
don't hesitate you know to
um after you finish the ends on you know
to try with another environment to uh
not to say to ask you know on this code
if some people try over environment what
environment you can use what type of
parameters you can use is you can use
another model Etc
um how do you see the group on Discord
so you need to go to Discord to sign up
to the Discord uh server and uh you need
to
um uh um there is something called a
rule assignments a channel called Rule
assignment and you need to click on
different enforcement learning and this
way you sign up to the Deep
reinforcement running channels
um so this is a way that you can access
this so the course will be taught taught
uh so using most of the library are
pytorch Library we are going to when you
will code from scratch some of the
agents it will be with pytorch but
obviously we give some additional
resources so if you want for instance to
to to code your own with tensorflow we
provide some additional resources
um on that but the course is mostly
focused on pytorch we're going to talk
also a little bit on um on the on Jax
you know because there's a lot of things
going on with tracks but we will not
have some ends on that but we'll provide
um some some additional resources so
that you can go further
um and the last
one is as I said you know Define the
schedule to stay in sync
um this way you know you will not finish
everything one week before uh before the
deadline uh the tourist units we wanted
but to to be to so that the most people
can can participate in the course so you
just need to have a computer a Google
collab a Google collab account which the
freedom is is enough for what we want to
do
um can we use physical simulation like
populate yeah yeah we will have one of
the units where we also have a pi bullet
uh environment so for people who don't
know what spiblet is it's like uh
modrico so it's environment where you
physical environment for instance you
train
um
um like a pair of legs to walk uh you
train uh some weird robots to walk or to
to to jump or to do that kind of thing
and you need to again face account
uh so if you don't have an account yet
you will need one and it's free it's
very free you don't need to pay anything
uh for this course uh so yeah
um so from from this this thing uh it's
a q a time
um so the idea is that if you have some
question about the course about the
content about whatever you want uh I
will reply them if uh it's out of the
scope or I can't answer because maybe
accountants are everything don't
hesitate also to go to the Discord
community and to exchange because uh
there is a lot of Exchange in there and
there you will find the solution of your
transfer of your question and what I'm
going to do during this um ends on to be
a little bit funnier is that I'm going
to play with some of the Hagi uh so if
you train some Huggy please tell me the
name of your model so that I can load it
uh I'm just share every step instead
correctly yeah I will let on this uh
size storage because I need to see on
the right hand you know the the question
um
could you give an approximate horse per
week uh so first let me hello so when
I'm going to to train your Huggy and
we're going to push to the herb after
that we'll be able to load your model so
yeah so we're going to improve the UI
for that but you need to scroll to find
yours so functions let's take this one
and you have different models so the
model the best model is this one again
but if you want to play content if
you're older because what's going to
happen is that every 5000 steps of
training yo you will save a version of
the model
turn off the song Sorry do you hear the
sound of the
of the game
oh yeah sorry
um
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we can't share it yeah
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
I'm sorry for that I thought that she
has a son because I cut on my ones
um
okay
[Music]
okay let's start to answer our question
and we'll try to find a solution so
um could you give an approximate hours
per week we should dedicate uh for the
course
um so uh it really depends on on on the
um
on the on on the unit because some units
will take less time but most of the time
it will be two hours per unit but some
will take a little bit more of time uh
again don't hesitate to
um to um
uh to to create your own status because
we let more time when we published the
last unit we still have one month and a
half to finish uh to finish uh the
course so it we will we put every we
will put every week or what what will be
the estimated time
and you can just increase the make
volume and then decrease the master
volume yeah but the master volume is
Cuts oh no I know why okay I think I
know why yeah okay uh let's start let's
try again and maybe this time it will
work
yeah start screen
window
okay
with Volta
uh notes I'm sorry I don't know what I'm
um but yeah I can check
um I'm just not what I don't know this
Library
so do you do you see
you know
sorry for the okay yes money you can see
uh is this timer is the music or not
okay
so I suppose okay the music
uh perfect
um so I try to go back we can hear it so
just to add summary page algorithm which
area we can use model based yeah that's
a very good idea um if you want to uh
perfect so I'm going to load this one
first then I will load Omar one don't
hesitate to to give me the name of your
model so that I can load it so just to
show you in this game you throw the
stick to a geek so this one is quite
well trained long story short he needs
to learn to use his legs uh you know to
move his legs one by one you know to
know uh to move correctly and you must
avoid to spin too much
uh so for use a question about you know
the summary of a model what we can do
with the model uh the state space we can
use for instance if we can use for
continuous action space
Etc
um yeah that's a very good idea and if
you want again what I forgot to mention
is this course is
um it's no pencils course where people
can participate so if you have some
ideas like that you can first open your
issue or if you're ready you know
create a fork of of the of the different
class so of different Airline course as
the name of the report is called the
parallel class again face slash detail
in class uh you can you can collaborate
you can find sense this idea of you know
adding information about the model is
very interesting so don't hesitate
um if you need help to create the pr
hesitate to to reach us uh we can add on
that
[Music]
um
let me see okay I will try
is okay
so let me
go back to the new new load
it's not on the on the alphabetics side
so it's ah yeah
let's try
this one from and
let's see oh it's good uh what's your
let's see what's
let me check
your parameters value depends on the
environment is the intuition of uh let
me show you the
question so is the intuition to develop
adult figure parameter values is
dependent of the environment or
reinforced planning algories use it's
both
um for instance
um let me take a simple example if you
have for instance again like edge of
Empire where the long-term reward is
very important because you need to have
a long-term strategy in that case you
need to have
um
you need to have a large gamma a large
discount rate so that you know uh you uh
you will have um you will um
you you will be able you know to have an
agent that will focus on the long uh
long term so you will have some uh
interpreters who will be for the model
itself for instance uh the number of
layers the number of of uh
um if you use uh convolutional neural
network if you have a state the frame or
if you have a state Vector for instance
you use the multi-layer passatron so
it's for both you you have uh the
parameter Alpha both compartment and for
the model something important to
consider is that some of those uh some
some um some algorithms you can choose
with some environment for instance if
you have a continuous section space you
can choose true learning so uh you will
send this unit why you can't do that but
yeah it's very um
um it wants to become the environment
the true the choice of uh the
reinforcement learning algorithm is what
you want to do with this algorithm and
and uh what environment do you have
a different vendor so now if you're the
best parameter for for a calendar it
doesn't mean you can apply to another
environment so most of the time is the
Prem is the same environment is quite
the same problem with transaction space
you can use the same Epi parameters but
if not it's very different now you need
to have any different parameter search
is what we're learning in this course
similar to what open and AI might use
for creating strategy so what I
mentioned uh is that you we're going to
have a live next week about this
question because if you don't know chant
GT use what we call
um a reinforcement learning from Human
feedback
and uh it's a technology where you you
train your language model with some
human feedback like if it was good not
Etc
and so it just reinforcement learning to
train it and we're going to have a live
about that and in the last unit of the
course we're going to have some
resources about uh this subject
so do we have a calendar with the class
schedule uh yes uh we have the calendar
in the recommended if you check on the
recommended
um on Unity rule in recommended
timeline uh the recommended timeline is
always when when's uh
it doesn't want to give me practice
today uh the timeline is when uh
the moment where we put into the
recommended timeline is when we publish
the article so we publish uh normally we
published once every week so next week
we publish Q learning which is the unit
2. or any particular accommodation or
reinforcement learning book except
certainly
um one of I really like I forgot
so we put on the addition already I'm
going to put it on additional ratings
but uh it's a one working uh so the
editor is working and it's uh that
reinforcement running broken you can
find it it's a very nice one
um to be honest it really helped me for
some of the concepts that I maybe
sometimes have to understand I think
it's settlement Bartow is really the
Bible of after enforcement journey and
it's totally free if you go to certain
about your reinforcement running you'll
find it but I think that the working the
working book is also very good
and that we're going to put it on the
additional readings of the course
it is okay to share your work on our
detail publicly as well working on yeah
sure sure you can you can clearly share
uh I think it's important to share your
work so that you know you can
um you know
um you you can show to people what you
do and yeah it's always always a good
always a good um
a good idea uh we will touch on
Transformer in the course yeah we as I
mentioned on Unit Nine we have a part
about offline and enforcement learning
and decision Transformer I I don't know
if you know but we already implemented
this urine Transformer on the
Transformer Library phase
um we have a blog post about that if you
type again Facebook or decision
Transformer
um but we are going to dive a little bit
deeper and you're going to train your
own decision Transformer so for people
who don't know what decision Transformer
is it's uh we use Transformer which is
um is an architecture a different
learning architecture but is usually
used to train for instance language
model but also uh
um image audio extra for a lot of things
and now very since two years a version
to train uh to solve a reinforcement
learning program so it's it's um so
there is debate if it's reinforcement
learning or not Etc I will not dive on
this debate but
um it's um it's a very interesting topic
I think
collab yeah you can't you can't render
in collab a very slow solution a very
something called collab gym render which
is a library but what you can do is when
you push to the hub it generates a video
version of your item
so you can push to the hub this video if
the agent is not good you can push again
to the hub because
um the models on the Hub has git based
so you can make a commit a new commit so
um my advice is try to directly push to
the hub and see the results
or you can use Gene collaborander but it
does not work for every environment
what else have available activation
combination of reinforcement running and
Transformer bet so one of the main
application that is currently you know
trending a lot uh it's shared GPT
um and it's thanks for reinforcement
running but this model is able to be so
good
so it's one of the application there is
also some application in the foreign
[Music]
but there is
um if you search on the internet we see
more and more application real world
application of reinforcement planning
so yeah you need a little bit of level
of
title uh we provide
um some resources on that there is by
totally 60 Minutes that is really good
from in the high torch official website
uh so
yeah I think it's important even though
we're going to use reinforcement on the
library I think it's important that you
start to study by torch
um if you're waiting on tensorflow I
think it will be uh easier to make the
transition
yeah so thank you this is the the the
book I was mentioning so it's different
Force mentioning it's a very very good
book
okay
let me use Adobe AWS stage maker instead
of collab
um so we didn't test it but uh if you
succeed to to make it work uh you can
create a PR so that you know we can add
to the list of uh of uh of of product
you can use to train your agents
can render be used in places of unity so
blender as as mentioned by by Def
Francois is not a game and giant anymore
there was there was a part of game
engine company
and unfortunately no but uh we're
working on the library called simulate
at Hanging face where you will be able
to to uh export your blender scene as
gltf and be able to run it
um in our simulate Library so we're
going to speak a little bit about that
during the course and we're going to
learn a little bit about this library
but you can already
simulates
and a very interesting way to answer
this Library
with it
um so we have one of our of my
colleagues called Edward Edward
I treated uh the reinforcement library
is currently working on very nice
environment so with adding events of
course so you can use reinforcement
running enforcement when you go do you
will find
um and it's really really great
would be nice
[Music]
a lot of time
so most of the time it will be uh but
um every time you need to send a mail so
some of them might mean if you want to
take a little bit of Advance you know
you you're very excited to to learn more
about the course uh you can check the
addition
uh because we put links you know for the
book uh for the different books you can
read for the videos you can watch there
is a lot of series of very good videos
made by you know a very important
Professor uh that you can watch too much
you can get the first ID of what you're
going to learn with this course
um I don't know what you can you can ask
these questions in the Discord uh we
have you know Discord uh and you can ask
this question uh throughout the story
because I'm sure that some people
already try
I'm going to I promise come out to load
this one so
here not on this course for now but
maybe some people use it so if some
people you know uh convert the the
collab to uh to Sage mature we can uh
you know if we do a PR we can put on the
course again this course is a
collaborative one so if everything
you're very interested about and you
want to add to the course uh you more
than welcome to do it
[Music]
so I will put on my tutorials to you
know put in alphabetical order because
it will be much easier to find your
model especially because the number of
models getting bigger and bigger because
a lot of people uh starts to to other
models so we're very happy with that and
oh I use it again because yeah we I'm
not I'm sorry again logistic
it's trying to eat the hands yeah
yeah
but yeah I
I
was
so yeah unfortunately I throw it very
very far away
yeah
um also uh what I wanted to say is yeah
don't hesitate uh on the Discord to when
you have questions when you have things
uh I'm very active on the Discord and
people there is a lot of people very
active and so yeah don't hesitate there
is no stupid question there is no you
know or that kind of thing
um yeah it's a friendly place so yeah
don't hesitate really I think it's it's
you know it's research certain that was
saying that stupid yes question is a
question you don't ask so yeah don't
hesitate to to ask questions
Umar yours is very very good too it's a
little bit clumsy but it's very good and
yeah
um again you can uh if you type hugging
face so Huggy h-u-g-g-y hanging face you
can find uh the space and you can
directly play online
[Music]
um
yeah
I'm just checking
it's shovel your question won't hesitate
I'm just checking that I didn't forgot
to answer the question
[Music]
for me for uh what such Absolution for a
repository
I don't understand this one
um
this is a republican instruction for
local installations suitable for Jupiter
so for now we have the End Zone on
collab if you want to run on on yours uh
you need to remove uh it's it's GSD so
because every time
so it's uh it's the actual screen
element
you because I'm collab you don't have
the screen so this kind of simulated
screen you don't need to be able to
record the frame and so to create a
video of your agent playing oh how it
falls
so except for that normally you can
directly download and load on your
computer and try uh because I think it's
the only
um only library that you need to remove
because you don't need to use it
um yeah again don't hesitate to try uh
if you have something you should not
hesitate to open an issue or to ask us
on uh on on the Discord directly
thanks for the tutorial I had the chance
to look at today oh thank you very much
um don't hesitate if you have feedback
also uh even uh you know uh things you
want but we improve uh our God is always
to improve the course and to find better
way to explain Concepts uh so yeah don't
hesitate
or maybe have no it's it's defense yeah
if you play the game uh try to avoid to
launching to too far
um and um yeah so as I mentioned next
week we're going to to uh you're going
to learn about true learning and you're
going to use two environments one called
frozen lake a very famous one and tax TV
two but every free sorry where in fact
you will have a taxi that we need to
bring someone from one place to another
place and find the shortest route
[Music]
um
so this is and on the and the week after
we're going to have GP learning where
you will train your agent to play Atari
games so Space Invaders record pong
um any other games you want you know the
battery VCS games is all with all one
um
aggregating extra space for Google
collab on this task uh no it's a free
the free version is really enough
is really enough of what we want to do
for now uh you don't need extra space
just be aware but when you run GPU with
collab you use the GPU because Google
has to penalize people who click on you
know launch with GPU but don't choose
the GPU so just be aware of that but
yeah you're really fine with Google
collab for for the first part of the
course
and um I run so some someone try to run
unit one and it was fine thanks for the
info so yeah it means you can run on
your own computer
we also agree another version could be
nice
a requirement file we follow the
libraries and their version could be
nice my environment break spiritually
frequently normally if you look at
um uh we put a link you know with where
we put all the libraries that you
install
a requirement text
something to know is that if you use the
collab sometimes you can add an error
with you know the screen visualization
um the extreme
um there are some bugs but we know about
if it's happening you just need to rerun
The Notebook funnel we don't have a
solution for that it's a new solution so
why not solution especially with gym
environments uh but um but uh yeah
another solution is just to reload The
Notebook
um on that
and if you load on the on your own
computer what does it take to open an
issue if you know there is a library
that does not work because we can uh try
to search together what's going on
um do you do you focus on how robotics
with reinforcement running and physical
uh simulation so we're going to use Pi
ballet which is a virtual robotics uh
environment where you have multiple
environment but this course is not will
not use real robots
um but if uh if you use real robots and
things like that hesitate to share me uh
what you've done because I'm interested
in this topic uh to be honest I uh I
just start to learn a little bit about
robotics real robotics so I'm very
beginner on that but yeah it's an
interesting topic
uh the premise that especially with from
the ring and recording uh if you mean
about the the question of um
of the library uh yeah um so normally if
you run on collab everything should be
fine uh if you run on your own uh you
need to verify that you have all the
library installed so some most of the
time it's you need to install some video
drivers uh I know for instance if you
use Ubuntu various uh additional
libraries to install
um but not hesitate to reach me uh for
this uh this program so that we can find
the solution
will we see the musical environment
during the course uh since we're going
to use a piperlet uh we're going to put
on the additional resources for people
who don't know pipelines was open source
version for a lot of time was very
expensive
um
and we try to
we try to avoid that kind of library but
we're going to put on the because you
know it's not open source uh per se but
we're going to put on the additional
resources but if you want to use
fiberate most of them are notified
letters are quite the same but the one
from module but we
for instance for distribution
of summer so we will have
um some resources to to learn to use
module code
um
yes
um so yeah except that
um you can
yeah you can you can
um you can find me some features so if
you go to sleep
um you can reach us on Discord you can
find us on the course
um yeah don't hesitate uh when my
channel when you have ideas also if you
have like ideas because you know we
can't have also good ideas so if you
have nice ideas of things you want to do
or or you want to collaborate or improve
it's nothing hesitate
um
and
um
let me see
so yeah last thing I wanted to show you
uh
yeah we have if you if you never use
um Discord uh we have
um we have a Discord one-on-one
here
uh where you can you know learn how it
works you know because sometimes it can
be a little bit overwhelming when you
just started this code so this way you
will know you know what channel you need
to to to to check Etc so don't hesitate
to check is on unit 0 on the Discord
section
we're the course provides enough
information opportunities to discover
for Master's disease can we create a
reinforcement running research group so
um
uh you uh with this course it goes from
beginner what we call beginner to
experience so it means at the end of
this course you have enough skills to be
able to read papers uh research paper on
reinforcement running
the course is
um is the idea is that it's not a
research focused course but uh if you
are interested you can I'm pretty sure
there is a lot of people on this call
who also want to do some research and
reinforcement running in addition to
that we have a trading phase um we have
a new phase we a team of reinforcement
learning researcher and so we're going
to start to publish uh some blog posts
about paper explain
Etc on our blog uh so we are these
people are also on Discord so don't
hesitate to to reach us uh but if you're
interested in reinforcement learning
research my advice is uh check on the
Discord and discuss with people about
the fact that you want to do that or
you're currently doing that and also a
certain place I would say is obviously
the reinforcement and Instagram credit
um yeah I forgot to show the question
uh which was you know if we have enough
information opportunities to discover to
click on master of disease
um always we always put additional
resources so it's it's up to you you
know if you want just you know to to
learn the basis or if you always go to
want to go deeper but we provide uh the
best resources and if you have
additional Resources by the way but you
want us to add to the course again not
hesitate to reach us or to open
um GitHub pull request
um
let me go back I wanted to show you guys
to the Discord
um
and let me see so yeah as I said next
week we have uh Quran the week after we
have dick running we're going to have a
small break during December 25th 20th
January the first
um uh you know because it's holiday or
this isn't that I will be on to this
course we will be here we will be
reachable
um yeah and um if I can before ending
this live because it's yeah time time
flies uh if I have one advice to give
you uh it will be
um uh hesitate to work in group to
anticipate uh to ask questions when you
learn and most importantly and it's very
for me the most important is we provide
you Hands-On but on this day to do more
for you you know it's for you now this
date like for instance to Twitter use
you know just to think like okay I train
between I wonder what what over of our
number there is on the G block mutation
so you go to the digital Foundation you
find I don't know Mountain car you find
uh you know uh carpool Etc and so try to
try to read the documentation try to
understand you know uh what the state
space is what the action space is and
just try you know to train with your
with your with your model or any other
any other architecture just try you know
you will never break something and I
think the best way too long because you
know
if you just wait you know the enzyme you
will learn something but I think it's
it's not enough you know you you will
need to be curious and and just try some
environment because there is no a lot
especially uh because for a long time in
reinforcement running there was
um there was gym there was a bit Zoom
there was um what kind of a non-type
electron but that was not a lot of you
know
um funny environments now we see more
and more fantastic Minecraft we see
um we say recently with Ridley we see uh
ml agents so you know it's a very nice
uh moment to start uh to see if the
principles mechanic but um
so yeah my advice uh have fun yeah of
course obviously because it is not too
long when you have fun but uh yeah do uh
do do more things you know try things
try not to stay to ask on on you know
study groups like hey I'm doing that do
you have some advice or or don't you
think also and uh something we really
love is wanted to say to share what
you've done uh to share with us to share
on Twitter what is it to tag us on
Twitter uh to share on LinkedIn to share
on the Discord or wherever you want to
share it so that you know we can see
what you've done and uh yeah don't
hesitate to ask people if they want to
work together on on trending you know an
environment that is not entrepreneurs or
even on the course and uh and uh yeah
thanks and yeah we really we really hope
you you'll enjoy the course and again if
you have feedback positive only gets you
don't take to tell us because
um this course is a lot of work for us
it's it's it's it's
so amazing you know it's it's really
it's really nice so don't hesitate when
even if it's only you know a positive
one but also if it's something we need
to improve uh we really want but this
course today is the best experience for
you uh to learn different enforcement
planning
uh I think we run off it out of time uh
yeah it was a great pleasure
um so again as I mentioned next week we
are going to have uh so I'm going to
check where we can have the live the
light number two level of the same live
but this time we're not present uh we're
not present the course is already done
but we're going to have a q a some
exchange and some nice stuff
and uh but also our solution but next
week on Tuesday normally so we're going
to give you the information by mail and
by this code we're going to have
um presentation by Nathan which is one
of the reinforced learning researchers
are doing face about the technology
behind chat GPT which is reinforcement
learning so reinforcement learning is
starting again to to be something very
very very trending which is amazing and
uh yeah this is the right moment to
start deep reinforcement learning uh
yeah I think U-Haul and yeah I wish you
a good day
and uh yeah I see you on this one
bye